but the question now is how does this
work in new england there is no way like
the patriot way we've seen others come
along and acquiesce who've had checkered
past
this is a different story the guys
haven't done youtube videos and all this
other stuff running into their pool in
joy or next to their pool when they got
cut and released and having somebody to
videotape it by the way this guy's put a
lot of stuff out there how can this work
at the world where the patriots live we
know the one exception to all of that
patriot way has been rob gronkowski who
just retired after last year and and and
i i feel like the patriots trusted him
to be a little looser than what they
expect because they knew he was never
going to do anything that would
undermine the broader objective of
winning football games gronk was was
silly he wasn't selfish well right he
was selfish
i agree with you i agree so there's
difference between i agree with you but
to the extent there's a little bit of
selfish silliness from a b they can
tolerate it i mean it's one thing for
him to post a a funny video on instagram
it's another thing for him to be talking
in a way that undermines you know you
can't say anything about a teammate good
bad or otherwise that's not your job you
can't do this that that but but they'll
put up i think with a little bit of
individuality and they may have learned
where they had chad ochocinco yeah eight
years ago and they kind of clipped his
wings and he was never the same player
they stripped away everything about who
he was and it affected i think how he
played on the field so i think going in
they understand they have to tolerate a
certain amount of individuality as long
as it doesn't undermine what they're
trying to do which is when football
games what does it say to the power of
bill belichick and tom brady and their
presence constantly in that locker room
that they're able to multiple times take
guys who probably would not work in
other places and somehow find a way to
make it work it's just amazing and it's
a testament to the system to the
organization to everything that's there
when when you're talking about the
greatest run we've ever seen and may
ever see in the national football league
and it's still unfolding one chapter at
a time
you get an opportunity to join that and
and i think that if that won't get
antonio brown to take things as
seriously as he has to on the football
field nothing will he did show when you
saw in hard knocks the behind the scenes
that he was working very hard to get
himself in shape and the football so
that's there the question now is how
quickly can he be assimilated into the
new england offense which is one of
those offenses where you have to read
what the coverage is and adjust so
they're not going to just throw somebody
out there who's not football sharp and
ready to say figure it out that's not
the way the patriots have operated in
the past oh you're right and even if a
guy's out there it doesn't mean he's
getting the football because until you
win tom brady's trust he's not going to
throw it to you and they've had guys in
the past where they just disappeared
because tom brady wasn't ready to trust
that the guy was going to be where he
needed to be and it may take some time
now josh gordon i think last year got up
to speed quicker than we expected when
he was traded to the patriots by the
browns and it's going to be up to
antonio brown how quickly can he
understand the playbook how quickly can
he get the nuances how quickly can he
connect with tom brady and be that guy
to tom brady trust and it could be it
could be with antonio brown arguably the
best receiver from a talent standpoint
that tom brady's had since randy moss it
could be that tom brady makes a few
exceptions with antonio brown as well
and maybe if he runs the wrong route
that's fine because you know what i'm
still going to throw it to him he's
going to catch it and we're going to
gain a big bunch of yards and maybe
score a touchdown out of jealousy
because of their unbelievable success
that you detailed earlier and they
unveil the sixth championship banner on
sunday night in week one against
pittsburgh it's been us against them for
the rest of the fans or supporters or
teams in the league because it's the
patriots out here and everybody else
trying to chase them this could separate
even more if it works and we have no
idea if it will talent-wise think about
what the new england offense can look
like around brady and the weapons that
he will have going forward yeah we spent
the whole offseason fretting about what
they're going to do without rob
gronkowski now their top three receivers
antonio brown josh gordon and julian
edelman only the defending super bowl
mvp an incredible array and you've got
sony michelle who can supply punch in
the running game james white can
contribute to the passing game who cares
all along i've been told that if tom
brady makes a passionate plea to rob
gronkowski to come out of retirement he
may do it that plea may not be necessary
now they may have plenty of options to
throw to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports